okay but moving on to another movie that
i finished last night and then i know
you watched as well
uh yeah it's called i care a lot and
that movie
uh you know what i actually liked it no
it was good
i liked it i saw i looked it up
afterwards and saw a lot of negative
reviews
like what just like people being like
she i think there was this sort of like
their intention was to sort of get you
get you to side with her for some reason
yeah
like i i was thinking about that it's
like when she when she made this crazy
uh you know recovery from like
attempting to
or from her attempted murder basically
and she makes this crazy recovery
and she's like this hero i kind of think
that they were
trying to get you to like feel bad for
her and be on her side but then
in your head you're like wait this she's
the worst person ever she should have
died
yeah spoiler alert by the way
i mean you you won't really know what
i'm talking about unless you
like until after you're done yeah yeah
but yeah yeah
i don't know it was i liked it i liked
the acting i liked the
very ending like the very ending i was
like oh
okay what goes around comes around
finally you know yeah
no i thought i thought it was solid i
think you know there was some pretty
pretty ambitious [ __ ] that they were
asking you to believe but you know i
believed it for the sake of whatever and
i thought everyone did a great job
acting wise
uh dude who plays the lawyer what is his
name oh he's great
he's [ __ ] great i mean i don't i
don't want to just like sidestep
uh everybody all the cast i mean
was it roseman pike yeah that's the lead
uh she played marla i mean everybody
she's incredible
dinklage uh the lady who played the mom
everybody killed yeah everybody killed
him so basically this movie's about
uh this woman who she's like a con
artist basically she figures out she's
like
has his doctor in her pocket and her
doctor lets her know whenever she has
like an elderly patient
that's suffering from a disease mentally
and
isn't able to like take care of
themselves anymore so then she takes
them
into court and she gets legal
guardianship over them and she's
like a roster of just you know geezers
she's giving
she's kind of got a roster of geezers
that she just
milks she's handing out she's milking
these old people she's giving them all
the britney spears treatment just
exactly sending them away exactly
exactly yeah and so instead of free
britney it's like free betsy yeah
free free carl you know yeah and
uh you know something old lady named
gladys
free gladys yeah yeah yeah exactly
um but the movie starts the very
beginning of the movie is this guy
basically freaking out on her because
she locked her mom in an old folks home
and barred the sun from seeing her so
she
the sun's like so basically right off
the bat you're like this is the worst
person on earth this woman
like she's literally satan how could you
ever do this
in life and then as the movie goes on
you kind of realize they're trying to
get you to feel
bad for her almost it's like it's this
weird
like pulling of feelings where you're
like i don't know what i'm supposed to
be feeling because she's the worst
i just and so that's the only thing that
i thought was weird about the movie but
it's good i just felt uh
maybe it's supposed to be sort of
sort of like tongue-in-cheek like maybe
it's just kind of posing you the
question like do you feel bad
it's supposed to be a reflection of you
a little bit like right right right
do you feel bad they're like cause you
because you shouldn't yeah do you do you
because maybe you're associated maybe
you're an [ __ ]
yeah you ever think about that yeah
that's what the movie's about
hey bud you might be an [ __ ]
it might be a [ __ ] um golden globes
golden globes happen did you watch them
no
you didn't watch them no
neither i didn't i didn't watch them i
just know just i heard there was some
pretty good
speeches yeah i just how did they do it
was it just like one big ass zoom
call was everybody virtual i have no
idea
cause let's just let's just i'm just
gonna pull up a quick club we don't even
have to pull it on screen let's just get
a look at
golden globes 2021. no pull it on screen
let's
let's let luke play it yeah let's see it
yeah let's see some of the best golden
globe
moments all right i heard that um jason
sedakis
i just saw a tweet of like when harry
styles
leaves you or when your wife leaves you
for harry styles
yeah and it was this picture and it's
him
sitting there fully mustaching a tie-dye
hoodie
three two one that's cody that's [ __ ]
you
that's [ __ ] cody
i'm fine with that cody that is you
yikes
what's this
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] what is it i didn't hear it i
can't hear it he's
he's remarking that norman lear
is 99 and so he's just mouthing to
himself he's 99
wow
hi as [ __ ] no idea he's on camera
he's 90 wow didn't you say someone else
was high as [ __ ]
like like who was it jason statham or
something like that
no it's him oh my god my man yeah holy
[ __ ]
he's such a legend yeah bill murray oh
my god what a legend
was he even at the gun bruh too good
two people don't give a [ __ ] when you
have to send in videos for home it's
like
what for the for the what the golden
globes all right bro i love how
what's his name in the up in the upper
right is
that is like the guest room of his house
or the laundry room yeah he doesn't even
look give a [ __ ] he's like
yeah wherever he's just gonna be away
because you know
he's got his jeff danny he's got his
celeb celebrity retreat right now he's
got like
25 of his friends over he's like i just
need to be in a part of the house that's
just away from everyone
at least bill murray looks like he's
partying yeah he looks hammered
he's just what is this for again yeah
this is my eighth
martini i'm in my i mean he's like
in his party shirt yeah how could you
possibly give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean like yeah you got
to be part of an awards show but you got
to just sit in your house and be a part
of it if i was sitting here
needing to be a part of like the shorty
awards or some [ __ ]
i would be just yeah eating nachos i'd
be playing rocket league
i would forget that i was on an award
show you know
yeah yeah i don't know that's the other
funny ones
yeah all the ladies showed out
all the ladies taking it seriously best
dressed all right
cool nice she's looking good
looking good well i mean don't we who
was it that you said it was hot he was
high when he was getting
today his acceptance speech jason's
steak was it today
no it was someone else he looks stoned
as [ __ ]
these shots don't do it justice but you
can kind of tell on the left his eyes
look red
yeah it's like when rogan's high for big
ufc events
is he really yeah there's plenty of
interviews like outside the octagon he's
just
[ __ ] blazed just like
[Music]
[Laughter]
so yeah um gg golden globes
gg gg
you